>> Jonah Hill: Hi.
I am Jonah Hill and I am shooting this video
for the promotional tour of Moneyball.
I will be doing an exclusive interview right
here on YouTube and I want to get questions
from you so I can answer them during the chat.
Anything you are dying to know about me, well
here's your chance to ask.
Send me a question or video right here at
youtube.com/atgoogletalks.
And while you are there you can vote on the
questions that you most want to hear me answer.
You have until the end of the day on Thursday,
September 15th to ask.
So what are you waiting for?
I am clearly reading this off a sheet of paper;
I am not going to deny that because I am lazy
and forgot to memorize it.
So remember, tune into the live show at 4pm
pacific on Friday at youtube.com/atgoogletalks.
I am reading off a sheet of paper.
Good bye.